there's Justin throw and then there's  Justin throws arms the forty-five year  old actor was spotted leaving the gym in  West Hollywood California looking tanned  and toned  yeah we're just focusing on those biceps  if I could do this instead in Europe I  would and while Justin may be in the  midst of the final season of the  leftovers he's already plotting his next  move I'm actually gonna be focusing on  writing and so I have a few things that  I've actually already written that I'm  kind of tweaking and retooling and then  another thing that I want to write but  would Justin write for his wife Jennifer  Aniston the right thing came around I  would definitely do it  you know we toss her out ideas  occasionally but you know it's got to be  something that I want to write and  something that she wants to act and  which is harder than you might think but  yeah it would be fantastic we're able to  do something together  [Music]